World War III oh man I love to say it
yeah I don't know if it'll actually
happen it may already be happening it
may be that in 50 years they look back
and say that the Ukrainian invasion was
the start or should say the Russian
invasion of Ukraine was the start of
World War III but we got some crazy news
been circulating for a couple days
bricks that's Brazil Russia India China
South Africa and many other nations 41
uh countries are seeking to join brics
brics announced and they've confirmed a
gold-backed currency to be used
internationally it's going to uh compete
with the US
and I think it's likely the Petro dollar
uh goes away I don't know for sure I
can't see the future but if that happens
my friends those of you living in
America your standard of living will
drop precipitously yeah you'll notice it
it's gonna get really bad why because
the US for too long has tried relying on
Military might to maintain its economy
and this is what I think Donald Trump
was worried about and this is what's
going to come and bite Us in the ass so
we'll talk about that plus we gotta we
got a bunch of other cultural news
we'll talk about a bunch of different
stories
um
I'll save them for for later actually so
we can get through the intro without
getting in trouble on on this channel
but I just uh we'll leave it there and
then we'll talk about what's going on
with Ukraine potentially joining NATO
they had a meeting they said okay maybe
we'll let you join if that happens that
is a direct declaration of war with
Russia so you know
yeah
it seems like World War III may be a
real possibility as for the other
stories they're a bit cultural and
they're related to gender issues so
we'll just save save them for later on
in the episode so we don't get in
trouble but before we do my friends head
over to castbrew.com and purchase some
of our coffee you can get the rise with
Roberto Jr breakfast blend the
Appalachian nights we also have
Colombian and French roast this is uh
the best coffee I've ever had uh we
formulated it so obviously we think
highly of it but I really do think you
guys will love it it comes in ground or
whole bean your choice and you can join
the cast Brew Coffee Club this is our
company we sponsor ourselves and with
your support and your drinking of our
coffee you will help us continue to do
the work that we do also don't forget to
go to timcast.com click join us become a
member to support our work directly and
we're going to have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you
tonight at around 10 pm where are you
can actually submit questions and call
in if you've been a member for at least
six months or you sent it today at the
25 per month level you can actually
submit questions and potentially be one
of our dollars that we have on the
members only show so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more is Haley cunnington thank you
for having me Tim I appreciate it
you want to introduce yourself yeah I'm
Haley Kennington and I'm a journalist I
was research director and story editor
for the plot against the president and
daily wires what is a woman and I'm the
news editor for wrong speak public
publishing right on well thanks for
hanging out we also have the Irish men
who lives under my house and steals my
spoons that's you sound insane like you
do you hear yourself when you say things
like that confess Sheamus you an
Irishman lives under your house and
steals your spoons confess Sheamus this
is this is the man thank you for news
you're gonna go to church
insane confess to what your delusions
Tim I'm worried about you I'm worried
about you my name is Seamus Coughlin I
have a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes we just released a cartoon today
on lefties and the way they project I
think you guys are really going to enjoy
it we have a membership portal at
freedomtunes.com where we release
cartoons that are a bit too spicy for
YouTube there's one every week there so
if you become a member you'll be able to
check those out thank you very much head
over to freedomtoons.com and uh become a
member subscribe to us on YouTube as
well and if you get some kind of care
package when you become a member let me
know if it contains any spoons what a
Tim if you think that I'm planning to
steal your spoons and send them to
people as incentive to support my
animation business I don't even know how
to respond I don't even know how that is
such a ridiculous accusation it's such a
ridiculous accusation people are legit
gonna think that they're gonna get a
spoon from you now that's I I mean if
people subscribe expecting a spoon I'm
just saying that's not my problem or my
fault I think you should add one anyway
this well this man literally just said
on air people are gonna get some spoons
if they subscribe to me I never said
that I don't have I'm not giving you
guys spoons I'm trying to figure out
what he's doing with them nothing
because I didn't take them and you sound
insane
hi I'm Phillip lead singer of all it
remains anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary and uh I have no
information about the spoons here at the
at the castle so uh that's my story and
I'm sticking to it hey what's going on
Serge uh I'm serge.com and I'm ready to
start when you guys are let's do it we
got this story from msn.com bricks
gold-backed common currency a shock to
Global Fiat money system says Economist
as Russia confirms launch in August oh
boy is this one esoteric I'm sure many
of it home are like yo I don't even know
why I clicked the link to this video
because I have no idea what you're
talking about I'm sure many of you who
are in the know saw the headline and
went holy crap and I'm sure most of you
who are really in the now sad Tim we
already knew this but bear with me this
is big news brics is the principal rival
to basically NATO and the Western powers
the world operates on the US dollar as
its Reserve currency you want to buy oil
you use US dollars with bricks launching
this currency backed by gold they're
basically giving a massive middle finger
to the US and telling all the countries
in the world our money actually means
something theirs does not further we've
already seen countries like Saudi Arabia
trying to do deals with China or
actually doing them to trade oil in one
this means we are inching ever closer to
the U.S no longer having the reserve
currency and you know what that means
that means all of you at home you're
going to see your standard of living
drop dramatically and therein lies the
double double-edged sword when it comes
to International politics
the United States does not export enough
we export culture movies music sure but
other countries can do that other
countries can export a lot of stuff
so what do we really provide to be
honest military might when we want oil
we print the dollars we buy the oil when
any other country wants oil they need to
buy dollars from us from us first with
this deal from bricks that basically
shuts down our International Ponzi
scheme or whatever you want to call it
and then all of a sudden we have nothing
to trade what will the U.S trade for
brics currency that's the big question
what are we manufacturing what are we
exporting that bricks would want so that
they would give us gold back currency
that we could use to buy oil with yeah
so here's my here's my here's my fear
and a lot of other people's fears the
reason why the Deep State the
bureaucratic State the the neolibs the
neocons want war is to make sure we
don't lose this status so the likelihood
that we enter into a dramatically
escalated conflict is ever ever so
increasing to the point where let me
tell you how desperate the machine has
become
earlier last year or so I think it was
last year when Russia started using was
accused of using cluster bombs the U.S
the Western forces claimed that was
potentially a war crime now the West has
become so desperate that Joe Biden has
approved the sending of cluster bombs to
Ukrainian forces something that they had
previously said could be a war crime
this is what I'm talking about the
people saying oh you can't do that
because that's evil and wrong and then a
year later being like if we lose this
we're done for so just do it anyway how
far off are we from someone saying yeah
well nukes are no longer off the table
yeah I don't know it's a very
frightening situation all I really have
to say about it is this to quote the
venerable Archbishop folt machine if a
nation would behave more justly if it
were conquered it should expect to be
conquered in the United States has not
been a nation which operated in a moral
way domestically or on the international
stage in a very long time I've seen some
of that turning around I think the
overturner over Roe v Wade and the fact
that we've saved tens of thousands of
children has been incredible I think
there's been massive backlash against
the lgbtq agenda more young people are
waking up and seeing the farce of the
sexual Revolution But ultimately this
country has a lot of problems and uh I
hope that we can pull through them I
hope that the United States can be a
strong dominant nation that behaves
morally but that's not the track we've
placed ourselves on over the past 50 or
60 years so
I uh I hope for good things but I don't
know that I necessarily expect them
I mean considering the the the fact that
the the brics currency is it's already
in motion it's not something that's
being talked about anymore
um it feels like the writing's on the
wall that they you know the Petro dollar
is the time is is limited and I mean
people need to plan accordingly you know
if if we're in as much debt as we are to
China and to to other countries and
stuff in our national debts like it is
and we lose the value the the status as
the reserve currency of the world
interest rates are going to keep going
up and the buying power your dollar is
going to keep going down and so and it's
gonna have a massive effect on the
average person so it it
unfortunately these things are it's slow
moving so a lot of people have kind of
you know shut the idea of of a currency
crisis out because it has been something
that P they've you've heard people
talking about it since like 2008 you
know like since the the
the financial crisis people have been
talking about oh if you keep printing
money then there'll be inflation Etc and
we're in debt and I feel like the
average person is kind of be kind of
just gone numb to that and if people are
numb to it and they haven't been
preparing for it or they don't it's
going to come back and bite him in the
ass and as usual the the poor people in
the US and people on the margins you
know people that are just making it are
going to fall into poverty and people
that are already poor they're you know
they're going to be screwed and to be
clear the the point I want to make here
is that I hope that doesn't happen right
again I hope the United States is able
to maintain our status as World Reserve
currency and we turn a corner and start
behaving more morally with respect to
our conduct both in on the foreign stage
and domestically and and there's
actually some precedent to think that
that might happen just based on the last
year or two in the way some things have
improved in some areas but yeah I mean
this if we lose World Reserve currency
status if this country continues to to
spend and print money in unsustainable
ways and also get involved in conflicts
we have no business being involved in
um I think it's probably fair to say
that we're not going to be able to
sustain that and just like any nation
that starts fooling around because they
become powerful and hubristic we're
going to end up seeing our own collapse
but what if
the Democratic nominee for president in
the debate says
here's what we're going to do
we're going to invade Ukraine we're
going to uh in order to fight the Russia
like I shouldn't say invade Ukraine but
we're going to send booths on the ground
to Ukraine boots on the ground in Syria
we're going to build a corridor through
Syria turkey into the into Europe to
offset the Russian gas Monopoly and we
are going to do these things
specifically to destroy the economies of
the brics Nations to prevent them from
subverting the world Reserve currency
what if they just flat out came out and
said this is what we're doing and why
we're doing it because our economy is
propped up by the fact that we print
money and we don't export and the only
thing we can do is point guns the rest
of the world and tell them that they
must serve us and all of your computers
and all of your components the materials
in there are mined by children who are
working as slaves
you can have that or you can live in
squalor
make your pick
what do you do no the average person
would would decide to they'd vote for
they I think they vote for the machine
in two seconds and then make an excuse I
I think well the machine makes excuses
for itself right so I think the way it's
going to be advertised to the American
people is there's some human rights
atrocity or violation that's occurring
in these countries so now we have to go
step in and intervene
that's what they're doing now but I
think the issue is
when they were like cluster bombs or a
potential War crime and then Joe Biden's
like well might as well send cluster
bombs it's like okay
that's not going to work you're not
going to be able to go and say look a
war crime is happening and then we're
going to go ahead and do the same thing
that propaganda is not going to work
regular people might just lie to
themselves to justify why we should be
in war but
yeah what do you think I don't know the
whole thing is scary to me of course I
mean there's not a good option either
way as far as what you just said I don't
I mean
I don't know it's all doom and gloom you
know I mean in in reference to what you
said about Tim about uh cluster bombs
and stuff I mean the Vietnam War started
in 1954 I think is when and the French
were kind of doing most of the the
combat role there and and doing most of
the fighting and the US didn't actually
really get involved until 64. and then
it was a whole another 10 years
it's completely reasonable to say that
you know we're a year and change in on
the on the the war in Ukraine or
whatever and all this stuff that we said
we weren't going to send all of these
things that that the government said
they weren't going to be doing they keep
coming and coming back and saying okay
well you know now we're going to so
there's there's no actual line that the
U.S won't Cross or at least that that we
as a population can reliably say okay we
believe the government won't do this the
government has demonstrated over and
over that they'll say one thing and as
soon as it you know it comes time to be
what they deem a necessity you know they
say we need to we need to go ahead and
do this for this reason it's completely
expected or or should be expected that
if the U.S has said no we're not going
to do this if the conditions on the
ground demand it or or can an argument
can be made that the conditions on the
ground on demand it they're going to do
it and I think that is up to and
including a nuclear exchange with Russia
if if it gets to that point now I'm I'm
not saying that it will
but if you put Americans on the ground
in Ukraine
I could see that happening and I don't
see the off ramp for this to get to get
us out of of eventually sending people
to fight in Ukraine this is this is why
I bring this up this is the Tit for Tat
we say oh no cluster bombs you can't do
that then we do cluster bombs they start
producing an international gold back
currency we have this here take a look
at this William middle Coop says 41
countries have applied for bricks
membership this is massive this is what
what is this like just about a third of
the world yeah and I mean not many in
our government but well maybe with China
too many in government I mean these are
fighting words saying that we are going
to use a currency absolutely that is not
controlled by the United States of
America something that's very
frightening for those uh in the ruling
Elite here and to be frank it's those
are frightening words for your average
person too if they really consider them
because if we do lose our status as
World Reserve currency the quality of
life is going to diminish for basically
everybody in this country now you gotta
imagine the position that foreign
leaders are in and foreign nations are
in they see how we have absolutely
abused our status as World Reserve
currency and the fact that people need
to trade in our dollar and are compelled
to by the way the market functions
currently
in 2020 when covid-19
crippled our economy or at the very
least I should say when the lockdowns
and the overreaction to covid-19
crippled our economy what our government
did is they responded by engaging in the
most gigantic transfer of wealth that
has ever occurred in all of human
history and they gave virtually all of
the money to the wealthiest people in
this nation and devalued the currency of
everyone who had Savings in order to
engage in that transfer of wealth now
anyone who was paying attention at that
time said this is going to massively
harm those in the lower classes this
massively going to harm people who have
saved and this is also going to harm
people who own small businesses because
the SBA was expected to handle something
like 10 times its yearly budget over the
course of a month or two weeks in order
to get this bailout money to small
businesses now the giant businesses that
got what 4.2 trillion in low interest
loans
and we're able to leverage that to
purchase up a lot of those smaller
businesses after they closed down and it
was done with your currency being
devalued now poor and working-class
people don't have a whole lot of
recourse for that but you know who does
have a lot of recourse for that
rich people in other nations who are
holding U.S currency who didn't get that
payout as well as oligarchs in rulers of
other countries that have stashed U.S
dollars because they had some faith that
the United States dollar was going to
carry its value over into the future and
many of them are saying you know what
we're probably going to use our clout to
punish the American dollar and punish
people who are in control of it by
pulling out and signing on to some new
currency
what gets me uh kind of worried is uh
let me just jump jump to this story
we'll keep uh again we'll keep it all
particularly esoteric we have this from
coindesk BlackRock CEO Larry Fink says
Bitcoin could revolutionize Finance
a lot of people are starting to ask
themselves why it is the CEO of
BlackRock this massive financial
institution is all of a sudden doing a
turnaround and supporting Bitcoin
that one's kind of concerning or I
should say disconcerting when there's
talk of the U.S losing its status as
Reserve currency especially over the
past several years and now more so with
brics Nations launching launching a gold
back currency the idea this guy's going
to come out and be like I care about
people and I think you know they should
listen I don't know maybe I shouldn't
say anything
Maybe not maybe what happens is and
again I don't know I'm not a finance guy
so don't take my advice for it if the
U.S loses its status as the reserve
currency War breaks out the dollar is
going to fall to garbage you're not
gonna you're not gonna be eating bread
you're gonna be eating bugs and living
in a pod and that's that's what I wonder
about all this when they say you will
owe nothing and you will be happy
maybe what they're not people think
they're saying they're going to take the
world from you maybe what they're really
saying is when the war happens you ain't
getting none of this stuff no matter
what you do the food's gonna be going to
the soldiers to the front line resource
and everything will be straight into war
and what will you have worthless green
pieces of paper to be honest digital
numbers on a computer screen we'll see
rationing all over again during the
second world war that was a reality
people could only consume so many
resources regardless of their level of
wealth because the government was saying
we need to use this rubber or fuel or
food for the war effort so let me ask
you guys what makes more sense
that powerful Elites in Europe and the
USA want you to eat bugs because of
their ideology or they were preparing
you for eating bugs because ain't gonna
be no food when War breaks out well I I
think it's a combination I think that if
your ideology is so corrupt and you hold
human life so cheap then it's inevitably
going to be the case you'll make the
sorts of Reckless decisions that will
result in your economy being destroyed
and people ended ending up being plunged
into Warfare which will destroy their
resources and lower their quality of
life I don't think that it needs to be
either or I mean yeah exactly I think
that there there are ample reasons for
ideologically possessed people that are
in positions of power to say look you
shouldn't be eating steak you shouldn't
be eating all this beef you should you
know and and red meat and stuff you
should be eating something that's
simpler and something that's better for
the planet because there are people that
truly believe that the that the the
world is overpopulated and that we need
to significantly decrease the number of
people on Earth because we keep
devouring the resources and we can't
produce enough uh resources and food to
sustain the population that we have and
well I don't believe that I do believe
that there are probably cons a
considerable number of people in
positions of power that are capable of
doing something about it uh and actually
affecting populations and and policy
that will
could or at least could significantly
lower the the population of the Earth
and I think that the the the the the the
global warming um alarmism that you see
is is the most likely method so things
like you know you can't have cows
because they are bad for the environment
and these bugs are better for the the
environment are are compelling arguments
to people that are already ideologically
kind of aligned or are used to getting
beat down with the the the world is
ending because of climate change kind of
thing so I don't think that it needs to
be one or the other I think that that
there are multiple reasons why people in
positions of power would want to say
look you you can't live the life that
you've been living and you need to roll
back your standard of living do you guys
remember that uh there was a document
that went viral from some security
contractor that claimed the U.S
population would be reduced by like 60
we talked about this I never remember
seeing that document because it was
erased from everywhere about based on
what though so there we don't know uh
some kind of Defense Contractor put
together a report talking about future
plans and it listed the populations of
many countries as having been reduced by
like 30 to 40 percent or something like
that or more and the document was
deleted I don't think we ever got a real
explanation for it I'm not saying it
means it's true if I I hate conspiracy
theories so you know for all we know uh
they were creating a hypothetical
scenario in the event of war or
something like that but then this this
uh the archives all got deleted and now
it's really hard to find any information
it is as if it has been erased from the
internet it makes you wonder about
what's really being talked about behind
the scenes because look for we know
Occam's razor suggests this is just a
nonsense document some random guy said
the population would go down or
something like this but as we we see
more and more signs of major conflict
escalating like the clustering Munitions
thing is a big deal there's there's uh
fears of the zaprizia plant being blown
up I believe it's his operation one
right that's where they're saying that
the Russians have lined explosives
around it or something like that I don't
know
I don't know you know you get propaganda
on both sides
and you got to figure out who you want
to trust but isn't it convenient for all
of us as Norma Donald pointed out that
uh the good guys won every war
keep that in mind as you as you consider
the news that's coming out today with
all of these uh major conflict stories
but also I think it's important to think
about
we I talked about this during covid
uh and I don't know if we were talking
about the context of War but what is the
one thing that is guaranteed that kova
did it got people to move out of cities
yeah it decentralized our economy
you add everybody working from the
office if that office got destroyed for
some reason let's say let's say
everybody's working at office and the
fire breaks down people get trapped
inside that company's gone
let's say you push everybody to a remote
work and get them out of cities that
office gets just caught in a fire your
company still exists digital economy
people are able to communicate
facilitate and keep working
so it made me wonder when we saw kovid
and the the main result was large Exodus
of major economic power from large
cities decentralizing this economy sure
was helping us prepare whether
intentionally or not for a major
conflict
if New York were to get nuked now our
economy would still function to a great
degree because many of these people who
run these systems have left and they've
spread out even so it's harder to Target
pre-covered with all of the big heads of
industry in San Francisco in California
in New York many in Chicago a single
nuclear weapon your economy is gone
postcovid not so much they're not going
to Target the CEOs and all these
different random places even celebrities
and actors are moving all over the place
they're not in the same place anymore
the people running these blue states are
secret Heroes they're trying to get
everybody out of the Cities Russia's
still I mean Russia still is the country
that has the most nuclear weapons in the
world are their nukes as powerful as
ours though like I don't know one I'm
not 100 sure I think they're more
powerful no
um but they they have the Satan too
tidal wave uh bomb or whatever it's
called yeah some of them uh in fact the
most powerful nuclear weapon ever built
was by the Soviets sorry about wow yep
okay and they only was it only ever use
it a quarter yield or something or half
half a hundred megatons was the the
design and they only used 50 I think is
the and the the bomber that dropped it
fell two kilometers from the sky in the
shock wave because it when then it
recovered oh my gosh yeah oh my gosh
yeah I was terrifying I mean imagine
what they have now I don't think it's
nuclear weapons I think they're well
they're Way Beyond this stuff I mean
we're talking about a weapon from years
ago yeah a 100 year old bomb come on
they got something else already for sure
yeah anti-matter weapons how much you
want to bet they have anti-matter bombs
well I mean look we know that different
countries have been creating bio weapons
and we just know this because uh one was
released now Sir Francis Boyle uh who
was the author of the American
implementing legislation for the
bioweapons convention has stated as a
lawyer that these are if anything made
with gain of function research is
classified as a bio weapon so that's not
even like a conspiracy theory or a hot
take that is the author of the
legislation that governs these Affairs
specifically stating these are bio
weapons like anything made through gain
of function research and we know gain of
function research is happening so who
knows what's been created who knows the
kinds of ugly things that have been
engineered by uh scientists that could
be Unleashed onto the public at any
moment so we learned during covid that
Asians were more susceptible to the
virus because they have more ace2
receptors hmm think about something like
that we know that this particular group
of people has more of one type of
receptor in their lungs therefore they
may be more susceptible to a virus now
think about how they're going to make
bio weapons oh boy yeah they're going to
be like hey this particular group of
people susceptible to this particular
thing and then one day everyone in that
country is very sick that's bioweapons
and there will be collateral damage yeah
well no we also know like based on the
part of the world you're in and a lot of
genetic factors you can be more or less
susceptible to diseases this is the
entire point that gets brought up
anytime anyone wants to discuss like
colonization and the Conquistadors the
fact that the Spanish were totally
immune to the diseases they were
bringing over so they didn't even know
they had them someone could
theoretically engineer viruses and
disease that would be more likely to
wreak havoc on populations of different
people genetically that's terrifying I
always get real like and I don't know
how realistic this is because I have no
idea about how bugs are are engineered
or anything but the idea of Ebola with
like a three-week incubation period or
two week incubation period born Ebola
yeah just spreads around and it takes
weeks before you just start puking and
bleeding out your eyes and and with and
you're contagious the entire time that
the idea of that just terrifies the
absolute crap out of me because that
would run wild through through the whole
country and then you would have
basically everyone in this country
demanding lockdowns oh yeah sure oh yeah
yeah we did talk about this too I think
you know Ian asked the question when we
were like oh we're all against lockdowns
he was like What if it was an Airborne
Ebola and it's like that's a tough
question because now you're looking at
people puking up their organs and stuff
in the middle of the street but the
quest the issue is still you have a
right to choose if you want to take that
risk well but but there's there's
another Point here I think a lot of the
argument against like
vaccinations or forced vaccinations or
lockdowns or whatever it is they aren't
necessarily axiomatic arguments they're
questions of whether factors are such
that it justifies it so if you did have
an ebola if there was any bowl that had
like a 99 transmission rate and 99
mortality rate 100 you lock things down
except people trust to the government
yeah yeah exactly exactly but I'm saying
if that really is the case and you
really have those numbers of course
people are going to say yeah dude but
that's the thing it's it's not even
going to be a question because if you've
got if you've got like people like in
Mass just like puking and dying in the
streets and stuff like that people are
gonna voluntarily be like get the F out
of here get away from my house I'm not
going out it would be it would be a
lockdown that was completely voluntary
the police and I mean the only people
that would would be going to work would
be like doctors that actually could do
something and if if even because a lot
of times when you get to something if
you get to something that dramatic
there'd be a lot of people that are just
like staying home with my family yeah no
I I definitely agree with you it would
mostly be voluntary my point is simply
that when you get to a certain point of
transmission and mortality with the
disease lockdowns are going to be more
or less justifiable what will destroy
the world incubation period of two weeks
Airborne High mortality and a disease
that takes four to six weeks to kill you
so escalating degrees of severity uh
let's talk about the absolute you know
worst case scenario because if we're
talking about actual engineered bio
weapons these things are going to be
horrifying we're talking about a virus
that is Airborne
transmissible when a person is
asymptomatic
couple weeks incubation period High
mortality rate
it would be impossible to stop unless
everyone locked their doors and no one
did anything ever again what are the
chances of a government actually trying
to build that virus I think 100 yeah
and we may have it now yeah they're not
you know gonna tell us what's going on
but why wouldn't they do it I mean look
at nuclear weapons they can wipe out a
whole city with a single nerve
like I mean they can buy about multiple
cities with uh with a with a Merv 12
warheads and one ICBM I hate these
acronyms let's try this again 12
Warheads in one multiple a multiple
independently targeting re-entry
vehicles and uh in in uh that's what a
Merv is it's an intercontinental
ballistic missile you'd say like Merv
and ICBM and people like I have no idea
what you just said yeah I don't know man
it's tough are we sitting here spinning
our wheels and wasting our time arguing
arguing about culture War nonsense no
when you when you go to the highest no
no when you go to the highest levels and
you see this is the case let's let's
talk about the realm of domestic
politics in this regard
if Donald Trump's world view is is
really let's not have the war that
destroys the planet let's Shore up our
borders protect the United States
bring back manufacturing and become
self-sufficient because the long fall is
coming
and the alternative is no let's go all
out take over the world and Destroy
bricks in by any means necessary so that
we can stay on top of the world which do
you choose
I think I think I think the Trump angle
is the is the is the better one well
absolutely and not just practically
speaking but morally speaking Not only
would that be there would be so much
Bloodshed and lost life if we tried
doing something like that but it yeah it
assumes it assumes that other nations
don't have the right to develop
currencies while we're debasing ours it
assumes that other nations should be
forced into dollar slavery and have to
hold this asset this currency while
we're abusing it and showing them we
don't respect it ourselves here's the
challenge
the Chinese Communist party is pretty
dang evil they are very evil absolutely
so there's the the other argument of if
we just decide you know what we're going
to close our doors to a great degree not
like like not completely but we're gonna
bolster the American economy and we're
gonna focus on ourselves China's Gonna
Keep expanding they're not going to stop
well it depends I mean firstly China
does get a lot of money from the United
States just with respect to the business
that we do with them so if we just
started doing everything domestically it
would be painful for us but I also think
it'd be very painful for them I'll also
add that if we were to go to war with
China over human rights abuses if there
was like a real legitimate reason for us
to go to war if you went through all the
tenants of just War Theory and they all
lined up then yeah that but that's a
different question than just going to
war with them over them wanting to use a
currency that isn't ours
okay the justification is a massive part
of it yeah yeah I think everyone was
just in agreement with you Sheamus good
good I like that perfect shimcast IRL
here we are there you go
I mean I don't know the the whole the
question is what does a regular family
do
uh-huh yeah well that I mean that's
that's a very good question you've said
this on the show before uh but at the
risk of sounding like a broken record
I'll say it again for you I I believe
it's a good idea for people to get out
of blue areas generally speaking not
even necessarily because of this
question but just the fact that blue
States in uh blue Cities end up having
really bad policies they're going to be
a lot of people there who are like not a
good influence for you and your family
so I'll put that out there and then you
know it's it's recommended by federal
agencies even in the United States that
you should have some emergency food
stored up I think people should do that
just try to live as moral a life as
possible people aren't going to be
surprised to hear this for me because
this is the advice I'm going to give in
every situation but get close to Jesus
Christ really get right with God live a
moral life and then if something
horrible ends up happening if America
ends up being destroyed well you lived a
good life you did the right thing you
formed the proper relationship with the
truth let's jump to some domestic
politics here because we have this story
out of uh out of Georgia actually was
trending earlier in the day Georgia's
state Representative makes moral
decision to leave party
rep mesha Mainer quit the Democratic
party and has joined the GOP saying for
far too long the Democrat Party has
gotten away with using and abusing the
black community
that's it she's from District 56. she is
uh been in since January 2021 she ran
unopposed by Republican Challenger in
the 2020 and 22 Democrat primary
elections in the state and now she's
quitting won't be it's not the first
time won't be the last time
but I have to wonder what uh what's in
store for us in 2024 if this trend
continues because the reality is we're
not seeing the inverse Trend no this
idea of Republicans jumping ship and
becoming Democrats is just not a thing
it happens sometimes but not really
typically it's neocons and people who
want war siding with neolibs who agree
with them on war but when it comes to
cultural issues like her issue with
school choice Democrats say outright no
do as you're told and she was like I'm
out I'm out I I think that that what you
mentioned about it not going the other
way that it's not really neocon or not
really conservatives or whatever I think
that they all kind of beat feet in 2016.
if they if you were like a if you were
anti-trump or whatever and you were an
establishment type Republican they kind
of had already have already left the
party and they did it years ago
um so would speak to speak to this
phenomenon of Democrats I mean you see
it
you see it in the you know in the
political space but you also see it you
know with uh what's her name Anna
kasparian
um there was another leftist that had
recently come out and and left you know
essentially left the left and a lot of
it is because they find out that the
narrative that is spun by the left
generally does not map onto the truth or
doesn't map on re onto reality
um and
there are going to be people that are
going to disagree about the places where
it doesn't map onto reality but I think
that the LGBT issues when it comes to
transitioning kids is where the breaking
point for most people are it's like look
you cannot you cannot have trans kids
you cannot have kids that are
prepubescent that you're encouraging not
just allowing but encouraging at times
to live their lives as if they're a
different uh you know as if they're they
have they're biologically different that
is unacceptable to the mass majority of
the uh of the population and I think
that that's starting to show when it
comes to
you know I don't know the specific
reasons that uh that rep what's her name
rep what Maynor Misha Maynard yeah I
don't know why she specifically left I
don't know you know I haven't read her
specific story school choice was the big
issue she wanted parents to be able to
she she was concerned that many of these
schools were so awful that these kids
were struggling to learn how to read and
that parents would have a right to take
their kid and put him in a better school
and the Democrats were like no shut your
mouth see and that should be something
that is is
that should be something that is is
really important to especially poor
communities and communities that have
have kids that aren't you know making
they're graduating with with a third
grade or fourth grade reading level like
that is a huge concern and that's
something that you hear about all the
time so I I you know more power to her I
think that that's something that more
people should be concerned about
absolutely agree there are a lot of
issues that people say shouldn't be
political and most of the time when I
hear that phrase I roll my eyes it's
like well too bad it is political that's
how this country works we have one party
that's heinously evil
um not to say every individual person in
the party realizes that but yeah what
the party wants is disgusting and
horrible and will destroy the country
but when it comes to school choice I
just want to finish this thought when it
comes to school choice it is it's so
obvious from any framework from any
framework that this is the right thing
let parents choose where they send their
kids to school don't force kids to stay
stuck in failing school systems now I
don't know why I would have the
expectation that people who think it's
okay to groom and mutilate kids and kill
born babies would see that also maybe
parents shouldn't be forced to put their
kids in failing schools but even without
those other two questions that people
end up being tied up with their party's
language on and not examining critically
with the school choice stuff you just
got to think it's whenever they say
things like
you're going to destroy or defund the
public school system what they're
acknowledging is parents would choose
anything besides the public school
system if they had a choice so even
their own arguments against school
choice are Arguments for school choice I
wanted to say real quick uh
up until recently both parties were
discernably evil yeah and then you had
this Insurgency with Bernie and with
Donald Trump and then Bernie uh showed
himself to be quite a bit duplicitous
and Trump showed himself to be
particularly anti-establishment in some
areas and so what you end up with now is
a lot of people of influence in the
Republican Party who oppose War who
oppose these things that are objectively
evil and uh objectively evil and
adjectively evil and now you have still
the neocons trying to claw back power in
the Republican party to once again
restore the two massively evil
machines in this in this country yeah no
well I think you're right that all the
elements of the Republican party that it
ended up shedding during the Trump
administration at least the bad elements
are ones that people want to restore I
think there's things the Republican
party uh shed as a result of the Trump
Paradigm in him taking over the party
that I don't think the Republican Party
should have shut I think the Republican
parties become too socially liberal but
when it comes to the Warfare issue oh
yeah I mean I'm it's one of his greatest
accomplishments was pushing the neocons
into the Democratic party yeah who was
it was it Mike Pence recently somebody
some Republican was like we don't care
about culture War issues they're stupid
I saw that yeah who was that I don't
remember we care about economic issues
it's like that's you're so wrong but oh
firstly firstly the two are unbelievably
closely linked that this is I understand
sometimes we want to separate issues
into economic issues and social issues
and sometimes that can make sense but
broadly speaking it's not possible it's
really not possible
um your social views are going to inform
your economic views I don't understand
how that could possibly not be the case
but even so to say well you know like
I'm really interested in slicing the top
marginal tax rate by three percent
um and I'm not concerned by the fact
that children are being abused and
systemically groomed through this
horrible school system I disagree I
disagree Jimmy Dore has left a lot of
economic stuff but not on a bunch of
other weird creepy stuff sure no I I
totally agree but I think that he would
tell you that his moral vision for
America is holistic and combines his
economic and moral perspective yes even
though I would disagree with them right
on how he applies those principles you
take a look at this uh mesha Maine or
democrat who's now a Republican and this
is a good example of someone who's like
yo I I disagree with this one issue and
they say basically get out of the party
the Democratic party is basically the
party of are you in the cult or not and
anybody not in that cult is right wing
it's is this how the media Works kind of
hilarious I mean you can you can think
about it in any in any context Jimmy
Dore
the dude advocates for very socialist
policies they'll call him right wing
however considering he is fairly
socialist on a lot of issues they
struggle with it you take a look at what
how they refer to me liberal on on most
on many issues traditionally not modern
leftism and they'll say that's right
wing because the only thing that matters
and what this Democrat is realizing
either you march in lockstep with the
cult
or you get out
yes
I don't care what they call me I'm not
marginalized step with them have you
guys seen the video where they're all
holding their hands up and they're like
I will respect my black brothers and
sisters you never saw that one let me
pull that one up it's such a blatant
virtue signal it's a cult bro I'll
mention this
um you know the Democrats will say if
you disagree with us on like point five
percent of our values you're in evil
fascist or whatever the right I think is
has become far too inclusive on the
other end where we just say anyone what
is funny what the left says is if you
disagree with the left on point five
percent of anything you're down on the
left and we say and you're on the right
it's like no no no no no no they're not
necessarily on the right just because
the left doesn't like them it's not to
say we can't work with them on the the
area where there's agreement it's just
to say we have to have some way to
define these terms like just because the
left is way too strict and purist
doesn't mean that we abandon principles
let me play this clip yeah
and do everything in my Powers educate
my community
look at this
I will love my black neighbors the same
as my white ones
that's color blindness look at this look
I don't think it's a code racism is that
a white person saying it too yes of
course of course he's like that is the
whitest group of people
that is definitely in Vermont
worse something like that hey hey could
be New Hampshire I don't see anyone
complaining about the fact that these
are all white people either how we're
talking about that post on Facebook or
Twitter because Cassidy how many videos
do we need to show people to be like yo
this is a cult that's super crazy I'm
not exaggerating I'm not being cute I'm
not being the richest I'm being factual
and academic in saying the modern left
is a cult it is a large cult yeah to be
clear they're praying like that's what
they're doing they're praying that's a
prayer ceremony right there they have a
leader up there who's leading worship
and they're chanting but that is prayer
it's the same thing as a confession of
faith in in Catholicism or it's the same
idea it's there there and there's
they're confessing that they're a member
of that particular no no this is like a
prayer service yeah I wouldn't yeah yeah
that's that's more or less what I'm
saying this is like when you when you go
to a church and you know the the
preachers up at the front of the priest
depending on which group of Christians
you're talking about and he's he's
stating something and the congregation
repeats it I mean when we're talking
about like ancient prayers that that
have a precedent and point to something
true good and beautiful that can be a
wonderful thing when we're talking about
ideological language that was invented
10 years ago in order to shame you for
the color of your skin well I think it's
pretty creepy but ultimately it is
prayer it is prayer and there's nothing
wrong with prayer and religion in and of
itself but there is something wrong with
these prayers in this religion because
they're wrong very wrong but dangerously
wrong you need to make a better argument
than that no
like the way the way I think about any
kind of true religious prayer yeah is
sort of a
name the religion that believes in a
higher power and prayer is effectively
an admission or uh you know in some way
it's rooted in knowing you are not the
end-all be-all it is not all about you
exactly there is something greater and
Beyond you and there is a component of
reaching out to the universe to God or
whatever it is you believe so I don't I
don't believe that prayer in this
context is just specifically rooted to
one religion in that context you know
Sheamus you might say Christianity
Catholicism is the correct one the rest
of people are praying to nothing or
whatever
what however you want to describe it my
point is this this is prayer to a person
yeah well exactly so I would say that
these people are praying to a person a
human one specific yes well so so what I
would say is that obviously Christianity
is correct I think sometimes people in
like certain Pagan religion religions
are like praying to Demons or praying to
themselves or if it's someone who hasn't
been introduced to Christianity before
and they're like trying to find God you
know when they're just innocently asking
questions I think it's possible for God
to you know hear that but that said
um I think that what you're seeing here
is a kind of self-worship because these
people are able to fit in with the group
by chanting these words and it's more or
less about that it's more or less about
fitting in virtue signaling saying I'm
one of you guys I have the trendy
opinion
that's a scary video man it's very scary
creeps me out I don't like it I I you
know to be honest with you I don't mind
it because I'm hoping that there can be
some kind of uh
some something brought to the Supreme
Court to get that whole ideology
declared of religion so that way you can
have it completely and totally
quarantined from legislation
have it have it be declared a religion
so that way people can exercise their
religion they can you know live their
life that way believe what they want
just keep it completely and totally
isolated from from State power so the
government can't you know give any kind
of past laws based on any of that any of
the the ideology well I think what
people have to contend with is a problem
that has existed ever since we started
talking about a separation of church and
state which is that we have determined
that one set of moral truth claims
should be placed in this category called
religion and other sets of Truth claims
even if made about the exact same thing
because they don't openly claim that
they reference a Creator or a god are
not to be considered religious and
therefore can meddle with legal
processes the reality is these views are
fundamentally religious because in
ideology is basically just a false
religion that does an expressly purport
to worshiping any kind of God and so you
have a religion you have competing
religions but these ones because they
don't call themselves that because they
call themselves something else are able
to you know have themselves declared
legally as National or state religions
basically we we need a a good legal
understand standing of what a religion
is the Supreme Court has a I don't
Google it because they actually have a a
specific
um definition and I believe it includes
like belief in a deity or something like
that no I it couldn't it couldn't
because then Buddhism I think is out
well yeah people have argued about that
before like Buddhism because it doesn't
technically say that there are I think
some interpretations don't I'm not a
Buddhism expert
um yeah I don't think Buddhas believe in
God I think it might does it does it
depend on the Buddhist or do they all
just say there is no God because I've I
remember learning about it as an
atheistic religion but I think some
might believe that there is yeah I think
I think I think Buddhism doesn't
necessarily require you to believe or
not to believe in a higher power okay
yeah like like base Buddhism does not
like it the Buddha himself would have
said that's that's incorrect because
it's a life path essentially it's not
that wouldn't be real Buddhism it sounds
saying that but uh no the the point is
that these are heretic Buddhist
essentially yes like honoring Buddha and
rubbing his belly and things with that
are our human things that have come up
later on they're not actually part of
the original core idea that Buddhist set
out when he was on Earth he didn't it
was not his thing but they would say
they're all human things though right if
they don't believe in a god
um
well they believe in Enlightenment uh
they do believe in a state of being
beyond beyond that which would be a
Kindle like heaven but again like
throwing the Bella you know that stuff
like that are human Idols that have been
created in time on that interesting I
don't see anything that specifies uh the
definition it brought me to the it was
uh autocorrecting to Scouts as in the
Boy Scouts at first
um so I'm still looking at I don't see
anything though so what do you think
when you see stuff like this
I think it should be classified as a
religion I mean it might as well be
um I don't know it's it's really creepy
to see him worshiping I mean what is it
that they're worshiping just the the
themselves yeah there's nothing else
there right there's no ethos there's no
moral structure there's no plan there's
no path it's literally just will you
repeat the words I say and then yes or
no absolutely
yeah well and I think some element of it
is also a humiliation ritual because all
right so so let's say we just take their
words I don't remember every single
thing they said but one thing is I will
like love my
um I I will love my black neighbors just
as much as my white neighbors now this
is like if someone stands you up at the
front of the room and they're like I
need you to say in front of me that like
you're not gonna go you know hurt
innocent people okay well the fact that
you're being asked that is an indictment
of you and the fact that you would take
that question seriously suggests that
you do need to answer that question uh
because we can't really be sure about
you so there's a strong element of a
humiliation ritual to this which if
you're trying to abuse people which is
effectively what happens with bad
religions and ideologies is you're just
kind of abusing your congregation well
you want to see them prove that they're
willing to humiliate themselves for you
either willing to put up with any kind
of treatment James Lindsay makes a
compelling argument that it's gnosticism
that and which it boils down to kind of
like like the the
the existing religions that people are
familiar with like your abrahamic
religions those are actually the devil
and that there is a God behind them
that's hidden from everybody
um and that God is actually imprisoned
in reality so the the gods that we know
of as abrahamic religion gods they have
they have imprisoned the real God in
reality and the God is in in everyone so
you hear people say well there's a lot
of times where people will make remarks
that they don't realize are actually
like a cult or Gnostic but when people
say God's in everybody I don't think
there's anything that's Catholic that
says that God is actually in everyone
but the agnostic religion kind of and
this is not an apology like the gnosis
like arnostic heresy almost yeah yeah
so so it's like it's as if God is in
everybody and the ideal is to have
everybody realized that they are God and
then once everyone realizes that they
are God that's the action that's the
beginning of history or the end of
History depending on the way that you
you are are describing it
um but yeah it's it's people believing
that they are God and they want to
transcend their bodies to to become one
with God or whatever and that's that's
part of why the the trans Community
transhumanism kind of mixes into it too
because they believe that their bodies
are prisons and if you talk to people on
the left a lot of times when they're
describing the way that they have their
their their their outlook on life is
they look at the world being unfair and
their bodies of prison and they're not
really free and you hear that through
the left when it comes to like oh if you
have to go to work then you're not
really free that's articulating that
they believe that their own body and
maintaining their own body is actually
imprisoning them and they can't be their
true selves because they have to go to
work and these are these are theme that
you hear the left talk and I'm talking
about the far left but these are things
that you hear the left talking about
frequently and it lines up with the idea
that it's it's a agnostic ideology or
Gnostic uh heresy yeah I mean it's
interesting there's a couple things
there and of course like we believe as
Christians that like every every human
has God's image and likeness uh on them
yeah but that's not something but it's
not saying yeah not exactly exactly
um that's basically what the devil says
I am God that's that was his claim now I
also think that you touched on a very
important point which is that in
gnosticism there's this kind of idea
that like the flesh itself is evil and
that you can transcend it in the sense
that your mind can be something other
than what your body is and it's Superior
um and the internal state of someone who
says they're a woman when they're
clearly a man must be honored above the
actual physical reality because not only
do the two not conform but the the quote
unquote spiritual reality is higher
gnosticism a little bit difficult to pin
down just because it's similar to the
New Age movement in the sense that
there's different kinds of varieties but
generally yeah I think you're right that
there's this heavy element of Gnostic
spiritualism to all of it yeah just like
this like gnosis this case hypnosis of
like you you're only your knowledge and
only your truth is the truth that
matters not objective truth there is no
objective reality yeah and I think
that's where I see it as well that's
what I think is is it's Gnostic in that
sense and one of the things that I that
I have heard people heard again Lindsay
was talking about this is that a lot of
the Gnostic uh Cults that have been have
existed in history actually kind of like
mask themselves onto existing religions
so they'll say to to Christians or
whatever they say well well God you know
you're getting this information from
from your your priest or whatever but I
know this this other part that is
actually your religion but it's a secret
part and that's where the gnosis comes
from they know this esoteric knowledge
exactly the esoteric knowledge the
secret hidden religion and it's it's
it's actually your religion but but your
whole religion not the place that's only
been hit because you've only been
getting given a little peace because the
people that are in power want to stay in
power so they only give you the little
bit I have the gnosis I have the
knowledge to give to you and it's done a
whole in throughout history Gnostic has
gnostics have used that type of argument
to infiltrate religions that exist and
and kind of you know turn like a
symbiotic relation no not a symbiote
Like A Parasite I guess well they'll do
the same thing I have the real science
science actually says biological sex
doesn't exist I can make that claim
let's show to the story from ABC News
Kansas must stop changing trans people's
sex listing on driver's licenses judge
says a state court a court judge has
ordered Kansas to stop allowing trans
people to change the listing for sex on
their driver's license this one caused a
lot of uh contentious issues there on
the internet as many people on the left
are saying it's far right fascism Etc et
cetera but uh my question with this
story is actually quite simple the
reason why I want to bring it up in this
conversation
if the left continually says sex and
gender are different
why would a trans person ever change
their sex on a birth certificate or
driver's license when they are not in
fact changing their sex they are just
conf they're trying to con affirm or
confirm their gender which is a social
construct yeah well right this is how it
started they created this nonsensical
distinction between sex and gender
gender is a term that was only used to
describe language so they took something
that only referred to inanimate objects
or or I shouldn't even call it an object
but an artifact of language and they
applied it to humans which already has
dehumanizing connotations to it
hold on they didn't do that we did it
because of what words naturally acquired
meaning
coined the term gender identity and then
on government documents It'll ask you
your gender not your sex yes so it's not
referring to the the to the male or
female nature of a word it eventually
came to mean biological sex exactly so
what happened was because people were
uncomfortable saying Saxon wanted a
euphemism they would just say gender
instead so some instances it was used
interchangeably and then sometimes it
was used to say well your sex and gender
identity are two different things
because your sex is the biological
reality and your gender is the
expression and they said that for a very
long time to get people to accept
transgenderism but now they've pushed
the two back together and what do they
say oh actually your gender is also your
biological sex because if you say this
is what you are we have to also say that
that's what your biological sex is so
the issue here is there's a reason why
we ask for the sex of the individual
typically for medical reasons
I mean that that's basically it
we can see the picture of your face on
the card if we want to know it's you
we'll look at the picture on your face
the reason sex is listed is literally in
case someone needs to identify your bio
your biology and they can't tell some
people are naturally feminine looking
and some women are naturally masculine
looking there are instances where people
are androgynous and so let's say you
have a heart attack and you collapse
medical person is going to come in do
they have an ID on them they're going to
look at your ID and be like okay they're
female okay we know
a bit about their body it's going to be
different from a male body changing it
does nothing to inform anyone of
anything quite the opposite actually so
if the real issue is they want to affirm
their gender and they believe gender and
sex are different things to the point
where there are non-binary people simply
because they don't want to wear a suit
or a dress then why would you ever
change sex on a on a government document
yeah well because you constantly need
the constructions of your own mind to be
validated and you constantly need a
grieving so you're just going to keep
pushing it down the line saying like
well you've accepted my gender identity
but you don't accept my sex I mean it's
all nonsense but you're absolutely right
you need to know a person's sex
medically especially if they're
unconscious and they can't communicate
it to you like you described different
medicines might be able to be used in a
specific situation but not another one
like depending on your sex it's also
true of dosages of medicines well so
this is this is the the print one of the
principal identifiers of it being a cult
the left adheres to things that make no
sense for no reason other than you must
that's it the larger group agrees on a
concept and you must fall in line with
whatever the majority of that cult
believes and does even if it serves no
purpose or makes no sense if you
disagree in fact this is actually
probably the principal component of the
cult the ultimate test will you agree to
something that is not true yes or no
and so as you can see many of these
people will come out and say
gender and sex are different and you'll
say okay they'll say also a person can
change their sex you're like hold on
hold on
if a non if a person is gender fluid
their gender can change and if a person
wants to get gender confirmation surgery
they are confirming their gender not
their sex you are now conflating sex and
gender as a single thing while
simultaneously arguing and oh oh you've
challenged us
exposing yourself
I think to a great degree the point of
of holding contradictory claims is so
that people who aren't falling in line
with the cult expose themselves exactly
do you what do you feel about this do
you think this is a horrible bigoted
thing I think it's ridiculous I mean
it's all about their affirmation you
know and they need to you know everyone
needs to confirm what they are but it's
definitely two different things and
medically I mean it's important to know
when when somebody arrives in the
emergency room and there's you know a
problem there's different
you know ways to go about approaching
the patient so yeah I mean I think
different medications yeah or or even
like CPR I think is a little bit
different or you know there's all kinds
of different things but this is just
it's it's right you're right it's a cult
and it's either you you know go in
lockstep with what they say
or you're bummed out which is why I
think the lady you had on earlier that's
great that she finally you know but they
only took one thing it only took one
thing for her to go against and then
well apparently it's been a year it's
been a couple years I just finally like
okay I can't do this anymore right I
wonder how far off we are from them just
removing the sex category from a
driver's license and having you put your
pronouns there and that's it that's all
we need to know pronouns are also
another thing it's all meant to identify
you as a part of the cult that that
that's really that's really it I think
it's all I I think it also adds to that
element of there being a humiliation
requirement or humiliation ritual I mean
before this ideology infested everything
the idea that you would ask someone
whether you should call them he or she
would be and should be considered
incredibly insulting right what are you
talking about well hold on you can't
tell I I I would welcome anybody there's
a meme going around where it's like I
tried the the the the lizzo test that's
what they called it oh no oh and they
like my and and my uh my aunt started
crying they they basically said he said
he went up to his aunt and said in in a
polite way you look like a trans woman
and he said his aunt started crying
that's mean and he was like but she was
very liberal and very pro-trans and was
arguing and saying all the stuff and
then he said something like well you
know you look like a trans woman and
then she got really angry and started
crying and his point was like why are
you crying if you like and respect trans
women and you think they're good and
beautiful why would you cry if someone
called you that because they're lying
yeah they're in a cult she knew he
wasn't calling her brave right yeah yeah
that's not what that implies
yep
so I'm kind of thinking about this like
in the future I'm not going to ask
someone if they if where they are
politically I'm going to say are you are
you in the cult or or not in the cult
and then just see what they say because
I've had like liberal family members be
like you're saying that I'm going to
call because I disagree with you and I'm
like no I'm saying you're an occult
because you believe things that are
contradictory and you're too afraid to
say anything against the contradictions
because people will attack you and you
fear that yeah see other people will be
like that quite doesn't make sense
whether or not they get attacked one is
free knowing uh freedom is dangerous and
the others are scared into saying things
that don't make sense and contradict
themselves like two plus two equals five
out of fear of what might happen to them
socially one's occult one's not yeah no
exactly I mean we in all of us disagree
on certain things I don't think we've
ever really like accused each other of
being cult numbers on the basis of those
disagreements so the idea that we're
just gonna claim anyone who's outside of
our values is a cult member is
ridiculous it's not about that like this
is a particularly strange set of values
that have incredibly strict standards uh
not even a set of values dude well we
values is a term that can just refer to
what somebody like literally values and
the things they value are very bizarre
when we had a particular leftist on this
show
we're talking about these books these
shockingly uh gratuitous books in
schools yeah and she goes so you're in
favor of abstinence only sex ed and I
was like No And she was oh I'm like
because you're in a cult right you can't
you can't you can't uh comprehend
contradictions you it's it's all just
anything the left says must be true no
matter what and anyone who disagrees
must be the other with me or against me
but look at who you I mean it is worth
taking into consideration who you were
dealing with and and the point of them
being but that's most of these people
well they're they're not they're look
there are intelligent political
commentators hey surprise surprise they
tend to fall in a similar set of beliefs
we can talk about uh Destiny a liberal
guy but he has no issue coming here and
and having a discussion because he
actually believes things and it's like a
real conversation about them yeah then
you have cult members who will say
literally anything so long as it fits
the cult narrative right it's not about
politics yeah like Destiny would look in
the information he'd he'd change his
opinion he's he's not going to like
totally be disingenuous he'll look at
something CC facts and C numbers but oh
okay you're right about that whereas my
other people would look at the numbers
would just completely look Beyond them
just so so when you mentioned the people
we're talking to there's a reason why
when we have Destiny on and have this
conversation it's not generating
millions of millions of clips and
millions of views and when we have a
cult number on it it does yeah because
Destiny's not a cult member exactly and
so people are not he's he's he may as
well be considered right-wing with them
at this point well seriously no your
political positions do not determine
whether or not you are left or right
anymore okay I mean is as long as you
anger that group to some extent they're
going to label you far right not just
right wing but like far right and
fashion if you say that Joe Biden there
is evidence that he engaged in corrupt
activities insert whichever one you are
now conservative if you make a movie
criticizing child trafficking they call
it a conservative movie yes they call it
faith-based religious
sound of Freedom was just a movie they
call it they call it on father and it's
Pro Q Anon and it's uh what else do they
say about it that it's it's for dads
with brain worms or something I think
that was the Rolling Stone review that
was published I mean I wonder why people
connected to Hollywood are so concerned
about a movie that sheds Awareness on
child trafficking becoming popular this
is the point there's nothing political
in the movie nothing no not really it's
a law enforcement agent tracking down
criminals and saving kids but you know
what else and here's the thing you're
correct that that's not political but to
them it is not only for some of the more
nefarious reasons we could point to but
just portraying law enforcement in a
positive light is already a massive
issue for them it does speak to the fact
that the the left
does politicize everything and and
they're going to be people that or there
would be people that would push back on
that and say well Phil you know the
right does it too or or whatever but if
you look at the philosophy of the of the
left and the thinkers on the left the
idea of the personal is political came
from the left like that that's what the
the early feminists were saying I think
it was the feminist that first started
saying the personal is political and
it's something that expands to to other
uh types of leftism or other genres of
leftism or whatever the the LGBT issues
that we see right now are because they
demand sexuality to be a political topic
it doesn't have to be it could be simply
look you don't teach children you know
sex ed
possibly at all because you know human
beings have figured it out for
couple hundred thousand years that human
beings have been human before we had you
know government schools so it's not like
it's necessary to ensure the survival of
the population the for the government to
explain how sex works that's not
necessarily necessary at all but the
reason to have these things in school is
because they can be made political if
you can cast something in a political
light and make young people start asking
political questions when they're you
know 10 11 12. then you can make
activists out of them and that's the
goal the intent is to make activists out
of kids so whether it be LGBT issues or
whatever the the dynamic is whether it
be race issues or whatever anytime you
can get young people activated
politically you're going to get a a
portion of them that are going to become
committed political actors and they're
going to become the activists of of you
know the Next Generation and stuff and
so the point is to politicize as much as
possible from the left with leftist
talking points or with leftist
perspectives that's why you have your
average mom and dad that are like hold
on we want we don't want our kids to
learn this stuff and the government's
you know sending the FBI after you know
because that's literally what happens
I'm not I've made up one thing all of
that stuff is factual things that have
happened so again I'll get pushback from
some of the people that are that are
friends of mine that are on that are
left leaning and it's like look I'm not
making any of this up this is just
talking about things that are happening
and have have happened so and I think so
the idea that the person was political
is something that that lives on the left
yeah no I mean I I would agree with a
lot of that I would say that and I don't
think you would actually disagree that
there are some in in probably many
massive goals with showing this stuff to
kids that go beyond just a mere
political statement yes but I I will
those are opportunists I think I think
those are those are I think it's I think
it's a mixture I think they're they're
opportunities but I think there actually
are people who want to upload like a
kind of systemic grooming and I'll also
add here that the reason we have sex out
of any form firstly I don't think it's
going to shock anyone to hear me say I
think this is something that parents
should be doing and not schools but the
whole reason we have these programs is
to tell people what not to do people are
going to figure out what they can do
with their bodies all right you have to
tell them what they're not supposed to
do so to show them a bunch of perverted
stuff that they hadn't considered is not
sex ad that that is grooming the purpose
of sex that is boundaries don't do this
thing don't do this till you're married
even like the more comprehensive
programs by the way which I don't agree
with that terminology I don't agree with
teaching kids about birth control but
even they'll say don't do this without
birth control like the whole point is
supposed to be about saying don't do
this Phil Phil brought up uh the FBI
wanted to jump to the story from the
post millennial take a look FBI
facilitated censorship requests on
behalf of Ukrainian intelligence agency
compromised by Kremlin wow that's a
mouthful okay so let's slow this down so
the Ukrainian intelligence agencies
going to the FBI and being like we want
these ideas censored and they're like
you got it boss meanwhile it was
actually the Russians facilitating it
how incredible is this a new report
released by the house committee on the
Judiciary and the select subcommittee on
the weaponization of the federal
government has revealed that the FBI
under Joe Biden facilitated censorship
requests to American social media
companies on behalf of a Ukrainian
intelligence agency infiltrated by
Russian aligned actors
okay uh let me turn wrap my hand around
this does that mean the people who are
getting who are doing the censorship are
actually Russian uh uh useful idiots I
have no idea no no so this the story is
Russians pretending to be ukrainians got
the FBI to censor people so that means
the people being censored were being
censored at the request of Russians Joe
Biden
his administration
inadvertently colluded with the Russians
to silence Americans yeah Joe Biden's a
Russian puppet and I think I can say
that well maybe because well here's the
thing people people accuse Donald Trump
of having been a Russian puppet I don't
believe that's true but if he wanted to
choose to be a Russian puppet he could
have been the thing about Joe Biden is
he's in a very precarious position
because it's very easy to become a
puppet when you don't have a brain and
anyone who sends him any information
that is vetted by the people around him
who supposedly care about him who I also
don't think are necessarily the
brightest Minds this country has to
offer can get him to say and do things
that are very much not in line with the
interests of this country
so yeah Joe Biden censoring people on
the behest of a foreign power because
there was misinformation spread by that
foreign power that eventually reached
him is not exactly a shocking thing but
I just want to point out once again
the Democrats were the ones doing what
they were accusing yeah the Republicans
of doing protection as usual Beyond
projection also uh smashed the FBI into
a thousand pieces and Scatter it to the
wins just saying yeah that sounds about
right yeah it sounds good to me I guess
the larger question is what do we do to
solve a problem like this
what do you think I have no idea come on
you got it it needs to be you you have
to figure this out first right now
pressure's on yeah I have no idea but I
mean you're right I mean he's a puppet
anyway you know you could get him to do
just about anything but that's
interesting that they've got it framed
like that the FBI was working on behalf
of the Russians right insane that's
amazing yeah isn't it maybe the real
goal is to deflect the US away from what
China is doing
I mean that's the Russians are working
with China the Russians want us
preoccupied maybe everything they're
doing is a distraction so that China can
move on Taiwan which is substantially
more important strategically than
Ukraine is to Russia before all those
new chip Fabs can be built in the desert
yeah and then think about this the
people who get centered on social media
tend to be right-wing and tend to oppose
the war in Ukraine
that's a good point why would Russia
want these particular individuals
censored unless they were targeting the
left or liberals or something like that
it'd be interesting I'd be interested to
see what those what the censorship
requests were what what was censored at
the behest of I guess now Russian moles
and Ukrainian intelligence which is such
a crazy statement to make but this is
amazing the SB this is Russian
intelligence sent the FBI lists of
thousands of social media accounts
accused of spreading Russian
disinformation which the U.S agency then
distributed to social media platforms
Facebook Instagram YouTube and Twitter
holy crap wow compromised by Russia who
could have seen that coming not on the
bingo card yeah we've honestly developed
a very strange view of Russia over the
past five or six years you guys remember
about 10 years ago
when Mitt Romney said that Russia was
going to become a massive geopolitical
threat and everyone laughed at him and
to be fair rightly so Mitt Romney used
to be laughed at but this was something
that even the left thought was
ridiculous at that time and then as soon
as it became politically advantageous to
them to start blaming Russia for
everything they did and they haven't
stopped they have not stopped and now we
have uh the administration I guess maybe
changing their tune on that of course
inadvertently it seems
Joe baijan yeah
I've been saying that ironically for a
while but the more and more that you
talk about it potentially being China
and Russia essentially playing playing
blocker for it that's what I kind of
think is happening it's unfortunate but
that's what I think has happened we
talked about World War III I guess the
question is is all of this a distraction
or what will lead up to say the invasion
of Taiwan which is really going to kick
things off
yeah I I there's part of me that's that
thinks that regardless of what happens
uh what the Chinese do in in relation to
Taiwan the U.S can't really do anything
about it as far I mean this is you know
this is an un uh unexpert opinion
because I'm not I'm not a geopolitical
expert or anything but I just don't see
the United States you know having the
the wherewithal to actually go to you
know have any kind of combat in in the
South China Sea over Taiwan if I
understand correctly where you know we
don't have the Munitions the U.S
military power is is is down 25 I think
is the the recruitment goal that they
were down last year that they missed it
by
um overall I don't know exactly which
branch had what the deficit was for each
branch but
they're not making recruitment goals
they're sending all of the bombs and and
stuff that we have over to Ukraine and
our stores of of Munitions of have run
low if I understand correctly so that's
that's also just good for a lot of like
the military industrial compact because
they want to make new ones yeah but what
I'm saying is I don't see how that's
true and I agree with you but I don't
see how how the US is in a position to
to actually engage in any kind of
Defense of Taiwan yeah especially if
we're
what amounts to a two-front war at least
logistically like we don't have you know
people on the front lines in Ukraine but
we're you know sending Munitions to the
Ukraine as if we're engaged in it so a
two-front logistical War I don't see the
us being able to handle that well I I
mean I can't speak too much to like the
tactics or what we have with respect to
you know Munitions or anything like that
but what I'm curious about is how the
United States would be able to get
enough people to sign up to fight in any
of these wars
um I I think a lot of the people who are
supporting the Russia Ukraine war are
not people who are going to enlist for
combat roles in the US military I think
that if China were to invade Taiwan
there's probably more people who would
be willing to enlist a fight that war
but I I can't imagine enough people for
that to be a possible reality would be
willing to sign up so the question is
what does the government do I mean how
does the government get people to enlist
if if this happens the moment there
becomes a true existential threat to the
United States all of these leftists are
gonna start scramming good the America
is bad and it shouldn't exist anyway I
think so yeah they're not going to fight
anything they're going to be like yay
yeah or run or or what they'll do is
they'll demand that other people fight
it for them this is this is something
kind of remarkable too when you if you
look at how much we've stratified as a
nation how much we've broken apart how
little people see themselves as part of
a common project anymore when you look
at what happened on 9 11 you know New
York City was attacked and a bunch of
guys from the south signed up to fight a
war because of it do you think that
Southerners would would enlist to fight
a war if New York got attacked today I
think few of them probably would I think
we don't see ourselves because at that
time it was understood that was an
attack on the on our nation I think
today we don't really see ourselves as a
unified whole and I think if one part of
the country got attacked way fewer
people would feel as if it was an attack
on our entire country and they would
just see it as an isolated attack on
that group of people I don't think we
view ourselves the same way we did in
2001 with respect to National loyalty I
don't think we see ourselves as as loyal
and also I think whether we would
sympathize uh with them enough to like
enlist in some kind of conflict or
whether people in other parts of the
country would is also going to be highly
dependent on who attacks them I I agree
with you pre- attack I think that the
temperament of the most people in the
U.S would change post uh dramatic attack
I think that that your assessment is
correct like the way that the the the
the the stratification of the the
population of the U.S has gone in the
past 20 years I think you're you're dead
on but I do think that a massive attack
that claims a lot of lives or is
dramatic would change now I don't think
that it would have the same you don't
think there'd be any change at all nope
I do yeah everybody thought that Kobe
would unite the country they're like oh
man this this virus no way yeah well I
think what I think what might end up
happening is there would just be like
competing narratives on which political
party was to blame even if it was a
foreign nation that attacked us people
on the left would say this is because
the right wasn't too uh wasn't hawkish
enough people on the right would say
this is because the left wasn't serious
enough about the threat I think it would
become a culture warish I think it would
be that first right if New York had
attacked today the the laugh would come
out and be like the right wasn't taking
Russia seriously and we've been
screaming and the rabbit like oh screw
you you know what you're talking about
you escalate attention yeah you were the
ones who are causing the fighting in
Ukraine we're trying to tell you to stop
we're not defending you this is your
problem you cleaned it up yeah true
yeah I don't know I still think I mean
when it comes to Taiwan I think the the
main reason that people that China wants
someone is also it's partly for like
political gain inside inside China to
say like oh we've United China looking
meant to for a long time it could be she
like all the Chinese presidents for
years had like their crowning
achievement it could be what he's doing
to like you know uh leave the leave with
his good Legacy but they need the chip
fabrication that's the valuable part and
that's so easy to to tamper with to
destroy it could be done with by
Taiwanese people inside the country
immediately I don't I don't I know
Taiwan or Ukraine is important for the
warm water port for Russia I I don't
know I just I just I think Taiwan as as
much as I hate to say it you know like
it I don't know if people would be
willing to go and jump for that war just
as much as they would be willing to jump
for Ukraine and be the same kind of
stalemate people aren't going to want to
go do it yeah well I think also when you
look at the country in 2001 people were
all willing to come together and agree
that Al Qaeda was an enemy that they
were real existential threat obviously
we all believe that that was misapplied
in retrospect when you look at the wars
we went to but today whether you're
talking about Russia you're talking
about China for the most part the
American people have no agreement on who
their enemy is other than to agree that
our enemy is one another that's what the
American people believe today that's how
we see the country's enemy
Trump said that the threat is not China
it's within our own country yeah yeah
let's uh let's jump to the store got
them from the post-millennial we'll talk
some domestic politics my friends we are
entering we're entering the beginning
of the presidential cycle so you did
have a bunch of announcements we've seen
rallies but oh boy this is where things
start to heat up especially as we get
into the next several months when the
primary races are going to get hot
because early next year I believe is
when we're going to see all the primary
votes actually happen so the ads are
going to start popping up right now and
here's the latest Trump currently holds
a 39 lead among GOP voters Nationwide
what I find truly fascinating is the
rate at which Vivek ramaswamy is
skyrocketing they say with Trump at 59
percent DeSantis at 17 uh Vivek
ramaswamy is now at number three with
eight percent and Rising I'm curious
what you guys think I think Trump's got
in the bag
I do think I would add to this in terms
of the democratic race it is fascinating
that there even is one there should not
be the precedent for this is that Joe
Biden as president is just going to run
again there's no primary but there is a
primary
and get this
RFK Jr is polling higher comparably with
the Democrats than DeSantis is with the
Republicans that I find really
interesting it's not a one-for-one
correlation
but DeSantis as probably the leading
Republican politician in the country
like Trump's not an office right now and
there's nobody else who's got anything
close to him can't get that close to
Trump RFK is at 20 percent doing better
in the polls as a non-politician
presumably because of how bad Joe Biden
is doing which I find fascinating so how
are you feeling are you riding with
Biden oh yeah no but it is interesting
uh because I feel like there's not that
many people that have been uh I mean I
don't know when I hear what's I don't
even know how to pronounce his name yeah
I know what is what does Trump call him
I don't think he calls him anything
he didn't get a name yet oh okay okay we
think it's going to be Rama swampy yeah
when is Trump going to Chris and him but
but he's not he's not an establishment
guy so I don't know
yeah I don't know but I like the vacuum
and I I think
I'm wondering if a vague ends up in
second place in the in the jupy primary
because the Dude if you've seen these
viral clips of him he is hitting it out
of the park yeah he's a bit talker
there's a viral clip where a woman
starts yelling about Republicans being
evil and a bunch of people get up start
yelling at her and he's like no no let
her come up let her come up let her
speak let her speak and he's like ma'am
I believe in the First Amendment please
say what you had to say are your mommy
say thank you for coming thank you for
sharing your thoughts and the woman's
like crying and then she leaves the fake
knows how to handle this stuff Trump
knows how to handle the press in his way
Vivek knows how to handle them in a very
clean and tactful way so I'll be really
interested in in seeing what happens
um as time goes on because Vivek is
starting up he's starting to pick up
yeah yeah well one thing I appreciate
that's being acknowledged here is that
in order for any presidential candidate
to really be successful or worthwhile
they have to understand that the media
is their enemy and they have to know how
to combat them
well Donald Trump doesn't seem to get
that
he can use his enemy yeah he called the
fake press all day night but he keeps
giving him interviews and one-on-ones
and they secretly record him and then
link it to the government he gets
arrested for it come on well it's funny
he knows they're there he knows but I
think he also engages with this in such
a way that if they air footage of him
saying something he wishes they hadn't
recorded him saying he can just use it
exactly and then he can also call the
reporter a mean name or something and it
just ends up being way worse optically
for the person to release the audio true
true fair I'm really interested to see
how Vivek handles this stuff because
he's not a politician he's got no record
he has ideas I like his ideas I like his
attitude he was talking I saw one video
uh today where he was talking about how
he would end the war in Ukraine and I'm
like these are bold and direct
statements to make he said he would he
would have like an Armistice with Russia
where they would it would it would
divide the country like Korea he would
then demand in exchange for these
territories they cease their military
alliance with China because of how big a
threat that man China have become
especially with the brics Nations Etc
and I'm like typically positions give
wishy-washy answers because they don't
want to be overtly direct them to Vegas
just coming out and saying it I like
I've said this before uh I think that
Vivek is is nothing but a uh positive
addition I don't think that he has a
significant chance of actually being the
nominee but I do think that his position
on the debate stage is going to make a
lot of people
make commitments and and discuss topics
that yeah you know establishment
candidates would never touch and I think
that's extremely good what about VP
ramaswamy you think that could happen I
think so I don't DeSantis is impossible
at this point they hate each other too
much yeah I think he's running I think
that's what he's kind of running for is
a position I don't feel like Vivek
really thinks he's he can win I feel
like he's running for to and he has he
can't admit that I mean obviously sure
okay no no obviously not no um but I
think that he's running for you know a
position in cabinet or maybe VP or
something like that but he's running to
to you know raise his star in in DC and
and I do think that he's got a good
argument and there's good reasons for
him to be running and I so I think it's
a you know positive I think a trump RFK
a trump Kennedy ticket and hits it out
of the park yeah I think you would see
tremendous margins yeah with RFK pulling
20 in the on the Democrat side if Trump
was like I'm gonna give you guys the guy
you wanted he could theoretically Paul
let's just say half of that let's say
half of the Democrats polled in favor of
our it's 10 percent of democrat voters
voted for Trump uh Trump wins no no
question well it's it's interesting
right because I've mentioned some of my
issues with RFK in the past that said he
has the Kennedy name he he's he has this
unique advantage of having a dynastic
name while also being anti-establishment
I like that word I mean it is he he's
got he's part of this political family
he's a Kennedy he's not just a total
Outsider in the sense that the American
people have no reason to be familiar
with him but he also is an outsider in
the ways that are meaningful to the
American people
yeah true he's got a bunch of dumb
tweets don't get me wrong I mean he he
was like what did he call the
anti-terrorist or something yeah I like
people are sharing that stuff I like but
I'm not bothered by it yeah and look I I
just like I said I disagree with him on
a lot uh I wouldn't vote for him as a
candidate but that said he does have
this unique Advantage I'll acknowledge
that I don't know I might vote in the
Democrat primaries and and for RFK I
mean I I like the idea of I think an RFK
leadership in the Democratic Party
forcefully realigns it in in a in a
positive way for this country uh I think
again I I would I would agree with that
in a sort of cautious way like I said
there's a lot RFK believes in that I
think is really bad but when you look at
how awful the Democratic party is right
now he would absolutely be an
improvement that's what I'm saying I'm
like yeah even if RFK on a scale of
negative to 100 to positive 100 is it
negative 10 negative 10 is a huge I
agree no I agree with the Democrat Party
I totally agree with you reluctantly
yeah and so you know I was talking about
Trump in 2020 and my and and I've had
these Libertarians be like what are you
really going to vote for the lesser of
two evils and I'm like I don't think
Trump's evil I I give him a net positive
score I mean the foreign policy was
tremendous that's because it's a
libertarian's perspective like they're
expecting you to see things like Liberty
exactly exactly like I think it's
because it's the archaic view of the two
parties but Trump was an Insurgent who
came in with a different perspective
well also and uh dude when people say
that to me it's like so I should vote
for the lesser of three evils and pick
your candidate I don't like the
libertarian either yeah yeah sometimes I
will but I I like the libertarian part I
like the Mrs caucus where is their
announcement come on guys what's going
on where who who's running with the
Democrats the Republicans are in full
swing the Libertarians got to get going
hmm I don't know I like a Libertarian
party but come on I don't know if
they're gonna have a candidate why do
you think because they because no one's
announced there was talking about Dave
Smith well there yeah exactly there was
talk about Dave but I don't think that
Dave's gonna do it I this is just a Vibe
I haven't I have no inside information
or anything but he if he was gonna
announce I feel like he would have
announced already yeah I agree so and
and you know it wouldn't be this koi if
wishy-washy maybe stuff yeah it would be
like we're in full swing we we'd at the
very least be be seeing him do more do
more yep because right before everybody
announces they start ramping things up
you can see the gears in motion and
we're like oh it looks like they're
gonna it's like even right to sandus
they're like next week it's gonna happen
then rumors circulated then sources say
and then finally he announced we've got
nothing from the libertarian so far but
but what I was saying about Trump in
2020 is like you know look I'm looking
at him uh the school choice
I'm in favor of
I'm looking at his Banning the wokeness
in Government Contracting because it
violates the Civil Rights Act agree with
that and foreign policy I thought it was
fantastic and so I'm like I'm not
looking at Trump as a lesser of two
evils I'm looking at him as like a small
net positive no new Wars
withdrawal withdrawal from Afghanistan
Abraham Accords massively net positive
so I'm like if you were to do the Trump
presidential quotient and took all of
the different elements of of the
presidency there's a lot of different
categories where Trump is negative and
there's a lot where he's positive that
leads us to on a scale of minus 100 to
100 Trump might be a six and I'm like so
I'm not here to praise the man and
scream he's the greatest guy who ever
lived in the god Emperor or anything
like that I'm just like you know I Get
Enough from it I don't feel like I'm
voting for a negative I feel like the
foreign policy stuff was was good for us
and there are of course some some
negative areas but overall we got a
great economy I can't blame the
president for covid I can criticize him
for his policies uh lockdown support in
the beginning I can criticize him for uh
not firing fauci but look I got to say
this at the time I didn't know better
better either so it's like those are
those are slightly net negatives but
overall we had three great years plus
they put weights on his legs that's
exactly it I look at RFK that's huge RFK
Junior I see a lot of really great
things in terms of calling out the
establishment massive multinational
corporations he's got he said stupid
things in the past I disagree with I
disagree with him on some of his his
takes as a reason of course of course
but like I was saying like wherever you
view him on the scale of negative to
positive he is a dramatic improvement
from the Democratic Party so I would be
interested in seeing him be the new
leader of the democratic party that is
say I don't know how the rules work
where I currently am at some states
require you to be a registered member of
the party if you're going to vote in the
primary some have open primaries I don't
like to inject myself
into like you know I wouldn't I don't
care myself a Democrat I don't want to
go to the Democratic party and vote in a
primary I don't do that in Republican
primaries however considering how
substantial and important it is I'll
consider voting in the in the primary
for RFK I I'd like just the dramatic
improvements over the Denver like the
rest of Democrats this guy works out I
mean wow talk about body positivity well
then I guess the the question for you
right since you're you're more far right
extremist right now
extremists in the Democratic party let
me ask the far-right uh Democratic
question
um since you are more moderate then I
guess the question is what matters to
you more a good Democratic candidate or
a good Republican candidate go Democrat
when we're looking at a Democrat and a
republican on the debate stage
imagine the cultural shift that will
happen if on strong cultural issues it's
RFK versus Trump and they're like we
agree right and we're talking about I
think there's truth in that because if
because if because a lot of these people
on the left will be like we hate Trump
so much we're going to agree with RFK
and it's going to force more positive
cultural elements on the debate stage
Biden's gonna say crackpot crazy stuff
to defend leftists and whatever he can
get whatever he can get from from the
media if they're forced into having RFK
on the stage
let me just say this you guys ever see
that uh Rogan episode with RFK where he
said he was concerned about potentially
being assassinated yes I'm not surprised
he said that I'll put it that way he's
he's a stark opposition 20 in the polls
there's a real opportunity to realign
the Democratic party in a positive way
that doesn't mean you have to vote for
arcade for president to be completely
honest I would I would probably love to
see a trump Kennedy ticket to be
completely honest yeah that'd be great I
I think that would be that'd be
something interesting I like the the
anti-establishment bent on it um and
whoever is most likely to do significant
or who is whoever's most likely to do
damage to the bureaucracy like
cutting jobs cutting parts of the
bureaucracy I'm not talking about like
small changes I'm talking cut you know
you know
actual cabinet level bureaucracy stuff
just get rid of them anyone that'll do
that I'll vote for
yeah you know I I would I would love to
talk with RFK and be like will you
commit to firing all of these
bureaucrats and setting term limits for
government employees I think you would I
think I think so too yeah uh I I I do I
do if anyone the dem's gonna do a BM
yeah he's the only one yeah literally
literally yeah and everyone everyone
else that's run like or that is is
running they're all going to increase
the size of government you know I'm not
a a member of the libertarian party but
small government is something that is in
my opinion extremely important because
it allows for you know different areas
to make their own you know make their
own rules this the the intent of the of
the United States is to have a bunch of
different experiments in in democracy
and to have you know
Federal level
Arguments for most of the things that we
fight about is completely pointless and
unnecessary so uh we're gonna go to
super chats and I'm gonna start by
reading this one from we are change he
says Joe Exotic for Libertarian
president with McAfee VP let's go plus
Sheamus is a dirty statist so the first
thing is the implication here is that uh
McAfee is alive
and the other question is he's not uh
hey hey uh hey Luke uh how you feeling
about DeSantis these days huh Mr Luca
Castle comes on the show and back I
don't like politicians but man DeSantis
is doing a really great job he's the
best and I'm really excited about him
and Trump's not good and fouchy and all
that stuff uh genuine question I wonder
where what Luke's position is on to send
us now uh only because what we've seen
is despite the fact that DeSantis has
probably the best track record of any
Republican politician in the country he
has not done well in the press his his
press team has handled things miserably
and unfortunately Florida Sanders what's
exacerbating it is his base is
incredibly
angry yeah it's like you I'll tweet
something in defensive to say this and
they'll still start attacking and
insulting me in fact they're even doing
they're still doing in the comments like
I instead of mean what about the guy all
day and they're still insulting me bro I
will not vote for the guy y'all are nuts
well I think that maybe those people
should be attacking an insulting Luke
instead of attacking and insulting you
that's a good point it's a good point uh
I'm interested to see where Ryan Sanders
goes I'm not going to blame DeSantis for
what his bad press team is doing but I
do think it's fair to uh criticize
tennis on who he's hired and their
inability to to to properly manage this
I think his record speaks for itself if
you look at Florida and see how well
they've done in terms of what their
coveted response was how they've handed
culture War issues that is that that is
a that is something good to vote for the
problem is his press team has been
apocalyptic and that reflects poorly on
him but uh let's read some super chats
and I'm curious to see what Luke stance
on to Santa says Raymond g Stanley Jr
says Tim if we're going to have a
nuclear World War III at least we know
we can take down a number one business
our U.S leaders care not about human
Lives May those who lead go down as hard
and as fast as Anheuser uh am imbev F
them yeah also smash that like button
and become a member of timcast.com
because the members only show will be
coming up in about 25 minutes on the
front page of timcast.com
here we go polite rude guys as I filed a
lawsuit in Texas challenging gay
marriage in America here is the case
number I can't read that whole number
the federal government is violating my
Texas rights interesting interesting
actually you know I'm gonna read this
anyway because Sheamus you want to write
this down based yeah it is sa23
c a 0 8 5 1 0 g I'd be interested into
looking that up and seeing what your
argument is because that's a tough
argument
how how something someone else does
infringes upon your rights
interesting yeah
I don't know
it depends on what um oberfel uh was it
is it oberg fell is it oberg fell yeah
oh Brookville uh it depends on what what
that uh actually is is is is arguing
because if it's an issue of churches
can't discriminate then the government
you know it'll be interesting to see who
the argument is
here we go
Joe spinella says per Dr Peter zihan the
dollar isn't going anywhere and how
bricks is being backed by gold isn't the
same way our currency uh once was bricks
will still go through using the dollar
interesting well we'll see uh we'll see
how that goes yeah I've heard I've I
heard that from him before yeah dos wood
says if you make the like button a child
I bet the Dems would smash it
that was brutal
yikes
whoo
freely Ashley says awesome to see Haley
on love her and her work thanks Ashley
right on
belly flop has a question for Ian uh
who's not here so it'll you'll just have
to answer this one all right Phil Ian
last night you mentioned getting
aggressive seemed like you were trying
to find the right word I think that word
is intense you get intense
yeah you know sometimes uh I will just
think about graphene
and it gets me so angry and it'll get me
worked up because if if other people
understood the implications of using
graphene and and and getting carbon out
of the air then you know we could really
move Society along 20. 20 right there
Ian cheers we are change says he did a
really good job in Florida during covid
but horrible foreign policy so what is
that is Luke changing his tune is that
is that well he has changed what else
did you expect oh
yeah yeah puke we are strange
it took me a while I had to write some
material this last week no it just came
to me really effortlessly because you
know when Luke's on the show I'm not
spamming the chat the whole time
insulting him I guess I have better
things to film Luke likes to get on the
internet and throw some mud that's right
he does that's all right we'll read this
uh William trash says my Law Firm has a
franchise group working with franchisors
Nationwide if you're interested for
Casper I do General business law and can
help members form entities for their
projects so the challenge we're facing
is coffee's up and running the uh the
new the current cups the new Blends are
coming out very soon it takes several
weeks to launch okay it took us months
to launch in the first place the
building we have
historic building requires a lot of work
and it's taking forever unfortunately
but uh we're getting there and it is
what it is once we have the first
location set up I think we're instantly
going to go for franchises because the
fastest way to rapidly expand and I got
a feeling we can have like 10 or 12
stores opened up within like six months
we can even do like investor stuff where
people want to open franchise and have
an experience let's say you are like a
manager for a couple different coffee
chains in your area and you would rather
run your own we could you know we we
could I should say this very potentially
we would be interested in if legal and
possible financing someone opening their
own set of chains and things like that
because my my goal with this is and I'll
tell you this right now guys
first they tell you in business never
say what I'm about to say to anyone who
you might work with
I am not interested in money
you say that and all your investors walk
out the door and say it was really great
meeting you because no one expects to
make any money if you don't want to but
I don't what I want is a success
successful business that can survive
that will be able to stay open that will
be able to make enough to pay the bills
pay the employees a good rate make a
little bit on top for a rainy day fund
but function I want a I want a bunch of
businesses that can survive and exist
and have a positive impact on culture
they need to make money to do that but
my priority is not to become a
billionaire from a coffee chain don't
care about that so we so when we launch
these franchises I think we're gonna
have like ridiculously favorable terms
in terms of Revenue and the only thing
I'm concerned about is enough off the
top so that we can have a fund to help
any one of the franchises should they
fall in hard times so we can keep them
staying open so
it's all it's all a beautiful pipe dream
as of right now until we actually get
the ball rolling perhaps the first thing
we should do we don't even need a
location is start discussing with
someone the basic format style guide and
structure of what a franchise should be
what makes it a franchise and uh
that's where we're at for now we're
talking with some people have potential
about potentially running this and uh
when that happens
maybe then uh we'll we'll get we'll get
uh get the ball rolling
get the ball rolling we will grab some
more Super chats Calvin Shaw indie game
says just get the Federal Reserve to
start printing bricks dollars instead of
USD Checkmate uh it's called
counterfeiting when you do to someone
else's currency that's right but North
Korea does it apparently yeah North
Korea has like a masterful USD printing
thing so they're just making money
anyway maybe they were the ones who did
it maybe they're the ones who crashed
the dollar
George M says post World War III
currency will be chickens and spoons Hey
sir can you break a chicken for a dozen
spoons I need exact change in all
seriousness people need not fear being
poor richness of character cannot be
bought well you know what they say
um I don't know what currency will be
used in World War III but for World War
four it's going to be chickens and
spoons famous quote you know what what's
what's fascinating is today uh wineberry
season is coming to an end
so most of the wine berries have begun
to rot and fall off we've harvested a
whole bunch we made wineberry cookies we
made wineberry candy it's like like a
chewy candy it tastes pretty good you
tried it yeah yeah it's pretty forced me
too yeah I have some like I don't want
to like have it yeah and and then you
know I was like raising my first name
and um then your spoon cookies were
really good we also today we made uh
Roberto Jr coffee cookies we used the
Roberto Junior coffee those are awesome
and then we we uh I made espresso with
it and then use it to make cookies
they're really good they're really good
yeah we made a crispy and a fluffy one
but um the reason I bring this up I'm
riding I I come up to the studio
before the show I ride up on my little
electric motorcycle and yo there are
berries everywhere there's blackberries
we got Allegheny Blackberry we got
another one I forgot what it's called
it's another kind of blackberry we've
got wine berries everywhere we have this
is the craziest thing there is a tree
with probably 5 000 grapes on it I can't
I'm not even I'm not even exaggerating
it's just you look up and you're they're
not big enough to eat yet and I'm just
like holy crap and there's grapes
everywhere I don't I don't know what's
up with this property because the other
freedom of stand where we're building a
bunch of stuff out ain't no food there
at all but we got Papa massive pawpaw
these are these are like there's so much
food here and there's ridiculous amount
of deer and turkey everywhere there's a
ridiculous amount of deer out there yeah
yeah like you'll go outside and they'll
be like 12. 12 of them I'm like dude
worst case scenario we got too much food
too much yeah too too too Bountiful you
know yeah I'm gonna bring like a bucket
and just go grab a whole bunch for
myself well I keep telling people to get
the wine berries because they're going
bad yeah they're about to yeah and so we
we Juiced a whole bunch and we're uh
we're making wineberry syrup nice we
Juiced them and then we made we took the
juice we add a little bit of water to it
so you could drink it it was really good
and uh right now the blackberries are
starting to come in then we have Green
Briar which I'm not super familiar with
but apparently you can eat then we have
grapes yeah yeah it's a Vine and uh look
it up Greg Greenbrier uh mulberries are
staying are staying for for a while it's
just it's my point is this man delicious
we're talking about conflict crisis lack
of food going poor the currency and all
the stuff
bro if you learn to actually live the
way people were supposed to live
and it's funny because we can we can
take the wef hippie dippy corporate
stance of like being in tune with nature
or whatever
however whatever you want to call it I
think it's a net positive if people were
living outside of cities and responsible
for their own consumption and refuse at
least to a small degree the world would
be a better place for one simple reason
teaching people responsibility yeah true
that's what's lacking people live in
these cities and they're like I'm gonna
go downstairs and I'm going to have
check this out
imagine what it takes to make a modern
American dish it's like yeah I'm gonna
have uh chicken I'm gonna have some kind
of like a Thai chicken with peanuts
shrimp chicken pineapple avocado
cilantro and I'm like bro you basically
pull a plant from every different part
of the world ship it all to your city a
tremendous amount of resources and then
eat like a king it's true a gluttonous
one you go to these actual country so
people like steamed chicken and rice
very very basic food but it's kind of
crazy when you think how you know I
walked into a supermarket in New York
dead of winter and there's avocados and
I'm just like it's wild that's crazy
they groom in Mexico and drove them all
the way up here yep but people don't
they're so spoiled by luxury yes so I'm
just like one of the best things
politically for this country would be if
people actually learn to live with
nature yeah definitely farming even even
if 10 of their food came from themselves
seriously they would they would take
things more seriously yeah if you think
about like apples like apples like a
frozen for a year if you see them on
like the on the Shelf today they've been
frozen for one year that's no that's
great that can't be yeah that's what
I've heard I've heard that apples that
are put onto a lot of shelves have been
in in cryo and freeze for quite some
time I think it's maybe I mean but we
have apple farms all over the place here
yeah there was one right here there was
one for sale super cool yeah for sale
for like a million dollars and I was
just like if I could own an apple farm
but I can't but uh you go you can go uh
fruit picking out here because they have
the Farms where they let you come and
just take it and you get like a little
thing you grab the apples off we have
apple trees on the property we have
three of them there's too many there's
too many apples yeah we got like 30
people who work here we can't we can't
get enough apples to feed everybody it's
insane like well for one thing like
nobody can eat 12 apples in one day no
you don't want to yeah your next evening
and next day we'll be back that is not
that is very uninviable you will eat the
apples and you will be happy you will
not be happy it's a lot of fiber don't
do it it is kind of crazy though because
we got Critters up to Wazoo like we got
bad Critters but uh I went to I went to
um I think it was Stonewall Jackson's
headquarters in Virginia I think it was
Jackson I'm sure and in the kitchen they
had a uh Smooth Bore musket above the
stove and then I was just like I said
decoration what's that for and they're
like nope it's Critter gun the chef
would open the back door and wait for a
critter shoot it and then throw it in
the stew wow wow yeah yeah could you
imagine like in your backyard I see a
groundhog bang There You Go dinner's on
like we we consider it to be like
hillbilly you know like you know Ma we
got dinner what's weird that we'd like
make fun of people for doing normal
things the way they were always doing
you know what that is that's literally
just rich people being snobby and
laughing at people who do things
normally yeah like oh his food comes
from outside
yes
I think it's his own food from nature
you had to clean it yourself
pops and Bruce says we need an official
Tim cast spoon in the merch store
it should
have shame is his face on the end too
falsely accused Sheamus falsely accused
now I'm buying it now Tim's Tim's you
just you sound insane you've started a
movement of other crazy people that's
the real cult it was really funny
because uh when we were like yo Sheamus
you have our sports like oh yeah I'll
grab him and it was like not a big deal
and then Sheamus walked upstairs and as
he's like handing us like a like three
or four spoons he was like an Irish man
lives under my house and he keeps
stealing my spoons but No One Believes
Me and that made it a funny joke yeah I
was like this look I know I told you you
sound insane you sound crazy you sound
like No One Believes Me he's trying to
make the story sound more rational at
this point but it's still it's crazy
you're the one that lives into the house
who says who says I live under the house
Tim says that Tim is an Irishman stole
his spoons you're Irish actually
ethnically yeah but I'm American see the
flag behind me talking about like I'm
ethnically Irish that's true all right
we'll read some more uh super chats
Sparky says Tim from year to year the
bug population fluctuates severely so in
many years there won't be enough bugs to
feed Humanity alone
I won't be surprised but I will tell you
this one secret technique you put wood
board that wood wood boards down in your
chicken coop and then every day you pick
them up and move them and you know what
happens there are bugs under them and
the chickens eat all the bugs and they
turn the bugs into eggs and eggs yeah
it's one of their many talents one of
the funniest things the funniest things
about having chickens is how the hens
are ravenous and the roosters are chill
and it's probably because the hens are
like they're craving food now it's not
because their body makes eggs yeah
they're always pregnant people don't
have chickens don't realize how many
eggs come out of chickens like you get a
couple chickens and your fridge is gonna
be full of eggs but so like when we do
sushi we take the leftovers like the raw
fish and we'll just throw it in and the
roosters just watch and then look and
they stare at it and the hens just go
nuts like like rugby that's what we call
it rugby and then like one will pick one
up and they all chase after it and
they're smashing into each other it is
crazy they're insane ravenous Little
Things
we'll grab some more Super chats
Alex Bean says Tim cast rules future
culture War episode guest ideas Trish
from teacher therapy and Joseph Everett
from what I've learned keep it up
yeah we wanna we wanna have that uh that
Harry guy Harry Sisson
come on Harry uh but he won't do it no
he never will never but it's but it's
because
I mean come on like
he's 20 years old he really doesn't know
a whole lot about policy he doesn't know
a whole lot about history or politics
he's just like a stock model
what is his talent agency like we need
someone who's young to convince young
people to vote Democrat you're hired
pretty much it seems like it so it's
going to be sheltered it's going to be
controlled there's going to be no free
form conversation of course not so when
we're like hey it's a raw two-hour
conversation it's just like whoa whoa I
can't do that sorry
yeah I don't think that'll happen
we will grab some more Eden
heideck says Tim YouTuber low y86 has a
video where Chinese domestic press
interviewed their Army's cbrn Warfare
Chief literally saying they're producing
and will deploy ethnically targeted
biological weapons wow ethnically
targeted
it's wild can you imagine that this is
only going to affect white people or
this is only going to affect black
people like which group too like
Scottish or English in the United States
you have such a mixture of different
groups but yeah
uh Apple fact here that I gave out a
minute ago
um
it's from the U.S department of
agriculture's website they say and a lot
of the average Apple amount of apples
being stored up to 14 months so the
office in nine to 12 months so yeah just
for everyone that's giving me trust me
bro give me the comments come on
cam girl as soon as Tim I want to talk
with you who I want to talk with you all
about conflict sometime you think peace
is always better than war and that isn't
true it's a huge blind spot of yours
that should be addressed hit me up on
the Discord anytime public or private I
understand the concept I mean if you
look at how the world is
conflict is a natural component of Life
all of it animals and all life competing
and conflicting and eating each other
and destroying things and I get it I get
it
maybe there has to be some kind of
conflict within humans otherwise we
become hedonistic lazy and we we have to
fall apart yeah I mean there is such a
thing as like a just war in the sense
that there are there might be reasons
for a country to become involved but
that doesn't mean that we should jump on
every single war that the media tells us
we need to join or become a part of
um I I love the secretary here demoralai
says let's see if Tim can go one episode
without triggering his DeSantis
derangement syndrome if I hear it one
more time I'll unsub what I love about
this is that like every episode we do
we've got some kind of criticism of
trump and not a single Trump supporter
has been like screw you Tim you've got
Trump derangements in your mama like we
literally say you're saying like you
hired a bunch of bad people he wouldn't
fire fauci he wouldn't turn and Trump
supporters come on and they still say
yeah well you know we get it but man
point out like a couple criticisms of
DeSantis and these people lose their
minds it's crazy like I'll unsub if you
criticize to send us one more time
Biden's over there go hang out with them
bro we're going to criticize everybody
like it's it's remarkable to me how our
position has consistently been DeSantis
has done a great job in Florida but his
PR team is bad and he's done some bad
things that have pissed me off and
they're like well for that you are you
have the incentive derangement syndrome
by the way I wish more of my fans would
threaten to unsubscribe when Tim
criticizes me with this insane false
accusations
accusation about shame as being Irish I
swear all in some not that well that is
a mean thing to but but when you say the
thing about the spoons where are my
people at where's my audience at come on
guys
you're just letting him get away with it
maybe we can with every purchase of the
Sheamus coffee a spoon comes with it yes
yes oh my goodness and then and then
every time someone buys them to him he's
like oh another spoon Sheamus took for
me I know what you're doing that's right
and I'll be like if you received the
Sheamus coffee and there's a spoon on it
that spoons mine we're entitled there'll
be a little there'll be a little note
being like you may have received the
spoon but it's not your property we'll
give like Golden Spoons out instead of
golden tickets and they can come on a
tour
if you receive a golden I actually don't
think we can do that but what you can't
send spoons out the coffee no I don't
think so what if you do that on accident
not necessarily maybe I solved a logical
conundrum
all right we'll grab some more here
thank you Tim
Jane Knox says we were exporting energy
under Trump do we not have enough oil to
mine and sell to Bricks yeah we don't
believe we do hmm
no the the exporting under Trump was
under very specific context and
circumstances all these other countries
had shut themselves down
and so we ended up with a bunch of oil
producers who could not store what they
had they had too much so we actually had
to just offload as much as possible
however I do believe we have more than
enough energy for ourselves especially
with Alaska
and we should definitely be working
towards that
yeah so theoretically well I'll put this
way theoretically the answer is yes
based on where we're at right now we
could be exporting however
we want to keep the energy for ourselves
especially if Brix is expanding
yeah so at least energy independent
would be good
Jason Hutchison says what did we do in
Afghanistan for 20 years but clear it
out and make ready for China to move in
yep and now they're going after uh what
is their lithium go down there I wish
you luck have you guys seen that video
of all the kids minding the Cobalt yes
so brutal it is I I you know
these Urban liberal types man they would
break down their their world view is
predicated upon
putting on blinders ignoring the fact
that they are colonists and slaver
imperialists masquerading as humble nice
anti-racists yeah but if you if you go
to them I guarantee you say hey
we want you to stop using your computer
your iPhones your cars they're going to
say well that's so stupid you're dumb
it's like I'm not saying it because of
capitalism I'm saying because you have
slaves making it stop buying the things
that are made by slaves they're about
don't know I refuse zero accountability
for anything ever it's never ever about
any kind of personal change they can
affect in their own lives and anytime
they do affect like a personal change it
always happens to be something which is
very economically convenient so they'll
say something like well I care about
climate change so like I'm not going to
have kids when they were already
planning to not have kids and you're
like okay dude stop like Noah yelverton
says oh no Freedom Tunes more like
Freedom spoons yeah I know well I
wouldn't need to because the spoons are
already free Tim has them it's nonsense
no I don't buy it
the yeti says Vivek will likely be VP
why they probably like each other and
more importantly Trump has zero ammo
against this guy
I don't know I I
literally make up ammo
yeah but Vivek is really good
so Trump will find something
but I don't know in 2020 Trump wasn't
that strong against against Biden you'd
think he had so much to go after and
people kept saying well it's because
it's sad to go after Biden that's why
they chose him I'm like I don't know
about that there's a lot of people that
said to go after that Trump has gone
after like I think a lot of the people
Trump has gone after have been sad
people yes exactly thank you for
mentioning it because I that he's like
the quintessential example he might even
be sadder than Trump or no I'm sorry
then Biden oh yeah it was it was bad
please clap
so all we had to do that's where we left
smile
uh what does it say smile Emily Sheamus
didn't steal your spoons Tim he's been
framed like a painting Freedom spoons
isn't a thing that's right thank you wow
freedoms good thank you I really
appreciate that did she say who stole
the spoons then
excuse me so that's not how a court of
law works I've been exonerated
they don't have to give you the real
spoon Thief my my bad
basically Sheamus makes some kind of
self-deprecating joke and then we all
roll with it and then Sheamus acts like
he's outraged no it hurts me
it really yo the story about me watching
leprechaun's a true story that's not
true I was on the couch watching
leprechaun too and I think it was two
there's a guy who gets bitten by the
leprechaun that's turning Irish and so
he goes to a restaurant and he's like he
orders french fries waffle fries mashed
potatoes tater tots he just like orders
all a baked potato and then literally as
the scene is happening Sheamus walks in
he's like hey man what's up and I'm like
watching the movie what are you watching
and he looks at the screen and it's a
guy turning into an Irishman eating
potatoes and he's like what is this
that's actually that's not what happened
Tim was watching this movie so Sheamus
Sheamus get in here get in here and I
watched and I watched and he said this
is what you look like and your people
are a joke to me
leave me alone I said I was born here
I was born in Chicago but everybody
loves potatoes no that's right thank you
that's true it's a hurtful stereo yo it
is really hilarious they made that movie
where a guy gets bit by the leper kind
of turns out I know that's insane
I love I love the low budget movies like
that I think that's either okay to do
with every group or no group that's what
I think
all right let's grab uh we'll grab one
more Super Chat
Raymond g Stanley Jr says return the
spoons to Tim or I'm unsupply
I would return the spoons if I had them
but the truth is I don't have them
I don't have Tim spoons all right James
Lynch says 40 years tonight bro
congratulations guys
well happy birthday I'm assuming you're
saying yeah all right everybody it's
time for the members only show if you
want to watch it go to timcast.com click
join us become a member and it will be
live in just a few minutes on the front
page you will see it just refresh until
it pops up you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Haley you want to shout
anything out uh you can just follow me
at on Twitter at ladykinnington and
there's like a link tree there you can
follow all my other work there right on
Timothy cast is a deceiver my name is
Seamus Coughlin I am an innocent man I
run a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes we just uploaded a cartoon today
that I think you guys are going to love
and we're going to be uploading one
Thursday which is going to be really
spicy which I think you guys are going
to really enjoy if you like me and what
I have to say subscribe to Freedom tunes
and become a member at freedomtunes.com
get an extra cartoon each week and
you'll also be helping support me and
what I do thank you very much and have a
lovely evening
I am Phil Labonte lead singer for All
That Remains you can find me on Twitter
at Phil that remains on Instagram at
Phil that remains official the band is
All That Remains on Apple music Spotify
YouTube I think I'm missing one apple
music Spotify YouTube Pandora there you
go search how you doing uh I haven't
used Pandora in forever I kind of forgot
Pandora we do really well on Pandora I
was really surprised I I just I only use
Pandora yeah oh really huh well uh I am
search.com uh you can find me on Twitter
and I guess that new uh Zuckerberg
Twitter or whatever it's called threads
stuff like that yeah look me up on
Soundcloud looking on my Instagram I
will talk to you guys anymore I don't
know I just think it's I just think it's
the it's the I don't use Twitter anymore
because I don't like Elon Musk oh yeah
and you know so I want to say uh we will
see you all uh did you shouted out your
Twitter already right yeah at surge.com
spill it out give me a second uh we're
gonna head over to timcast.com for the
members on the show but I do want to
give a shout out to Nate silver who's
currently in 47th Place in the World
Series of Poker yo legit uh that's
that's pretty cool to see his name pop
up he was actually in 30 some odd place
there's still a long way to go as they
eliminate players but this is a 10 000
player pool down to 211 players and yo
straight up Nate silver at 538 is
currently in uh 47th Place so good good
for Nate good for Nate it would be
really cool if he ends up winning the 12
million dollar prize just because I know
who he is but uh may not agree on
everything but it is cool to see that
you know he's doing so well anyway we'll
see all of our timcast.com thanks for
hanging out